and we are joined once again on the
programme by the vaccines minister
nadeem sahabi mrs howie really good to
see you this morning um and it does feel
having dipped my toe into social media
this morning seen some concern seeing
plenty of misinformation it feels like
we all need to take a few deep breaths
this morning because we are talking
about vaccinating children can you just
repeat the justification that was given
to the public yesterday by the chief
medical officer why do we feel it is
necessary
for 12 to 15 year olds to receive a
vaccine
absolutely good morning uh neil so uh
the joint committee on vaccination
immunization who have relied upon and
have they have delivered throughout the
vaccine deployment program have been on
your show many times
beginning uh back last year when we
launched with the fisa bionic vaccine on
the 8th of december um the jcbi uh
looked at the clinical um uh impact on
12th year olds and
came down on the side that that actually
being vaccinated is marginally better
but not enough to
recommend a universal vaccination
program they recommended that the chief
medical officers of england wales
scotland northern ireland
look at
the other public health and mental
health impacts on children not on the
wider population on those 12 15 year
olds
they reported yesterday and they have
unanimously all four chief medical
officers england scotland wales and
northern ireland have recommended that
we offer a one uh dose of the fisa
biontech vaccine to 12 year olds now the
way we will do that is uh and we've
accepted that advice
is through the school school-age
immunization service which has been
doing
vaccination of children for many many
years very well-versed doing this so
clinicians will lead on this in school
schools
will contact parents in the usual way
that they do and will require consent
parental consent uh of course and this
is voluntary there is no stigmatization
of any parent or
anyone who may choose not to have the
vaccine although i have to say when we
offered the vaccine last month the 16
and 17 year olds they came forward um in
the past month in their droves and their
numbers because they realize that how
important it is to protect themselves
and of course they've seen firsthand the
damage that the covert pandemic has has
done to mental health and of course
through schools as well but but just
just to go back to the rationale for
this part of the concern as i understand
it from parents who've expressed concern
is that we have in essence you know
clinical advice being given for
non-clinical purposes we have we have
doctors
advising 12 to 15 year olds to follow a
medical process a vaccination
for reasons which don't seem to have a a
grounding in the clinical side and
that's worrying people
and that's really important to uh sort
of
try and flesh out for your viewers
the chief medical officers
were asked the jcbi the joint committee
actually recommended that we ask the
chief medical officers
we asked them they also consulted with
the royal colleges of pediatrics
the royal college of gps and of course
the jcbi were in the room uh to look at
the mental health
impact on those 12 13 year olds at the
public health impact on the 12 15 years
not on the greater uh uh sort of good of
society it's actually for those
12 to 15 year olds the jcbi
were only sort of looking at what they
are narrowly qualified to look at which
is why they made the recommendation that
we should also ask the chief medical
officers they have now come back to us
and they recommend uh
the offer of a single dose uh for 12
year olds with parental consent so that
is what we'll be going ahead and doing
it's been a very just honest incentive
sorry
we've really got a finite amount of time
this morning i'm really keen to kind of
get through as many questions as
possible on the consent point how will
that be how will that be administered
again of course and a bit of
disinformation on social media this
morning i mean isn't it the case that
you know 12 to 15 year olds can you know
right now consent to other forms of of
medical treatment where their parents
perhaps have a different view
so the consent process the
school age immunization service um
are really
really well equipped to do they've been
doing it for years
for children's vaccination in schools so
children will have a leaflet that they
can share with their parents and of
course we'll have a consent form
that will go to them either
electronically or in some schools
physically to their parents and the
parents will then read all the
information
have to give consent if the child is to
be vaccinated on the very rare
occasions where there is a difference
opinion of opinion between the parent
and the 12 to 15 year old
where the parent for example doesn't
want to give consent but the 12 to 15
year old wants to have the vaccine then
the first step is the clinician of the
school immunization
service will bring the parent and the 12
to 15 year old the child together to see
whether they can reach consent if that
is not possible then if the child is
deemed to be competent and this has been
around since the 80s for all
vaccination programs for example in
schools if the child is deemed to be
competent the gillig competence as it's
referred to
then the child can have the vaccine but
these are very rare um
occasions and it is very important to
remember that the school
age immunization service is incredibly
well equipped to deal with this
clinicians are very well versed in
delivering vaccinations to 12 year olds
in schools
sure
let's talk though about about the winter
plan and this was something we explored
with with your colleague therese coffee
yesterday it is absolutely fair to say
isn't it that despite that the clear
inclination to avoid lockdowns to avoid
reintroduction mandatory face masks
social distancing and so on clearly you
don't want to do it but those options
remain in the arsenal don't they
so the
non-pharmaceutical interventions the
npis the dreaded mpis were our only
weapon against the virus before the
vaccines came along the vaccines now
are
the prime way we have been able to
manage this virus and that will continue
to be as the prime minister will set out
later today as will the secretary of
state uh make a statement to parliament
they will sure sure but let's again
we're really pushed for time lockdown
remains an option doesn't it social mass
social distancing mask wearing it all
remains an option it's just because the
prime minister will be saying you know
the pandemic is far from over but you
know we are able to live with the virus
without significant restrictions on our
freedoms i'm just wondering where the
tipping point is that would lead to for
example lockdown being brought back in
and so on
so lockdowns would be an absolutely last
resort what we're trying to
do at the moment neil is to transition
this virus from pandemic to endemic
through a
massive vaccination program we know the
vaccines have saved over 112 000 lives
24 million infections we're about to
embark on a massive booster uh campaign
uh and of course a flu vaccination
program so i am concerned about flu we
haven't had much flu circulating
anywhere in the world and in a bad year
you know we could lose up to 25 000
people to flee so the combination of the
booster campaign for covet which the
prime minister will say more about today
as will the secretary of state in terms
of the uh jcvi final advice which we
have now uh received and accepted the
interim advice which they gave us on the
30th of june helped us to plan
so planning has been well underway uh to
be able to i hope come back on your
program and break the record that we set
in the first vaccination program because
we have a massive task ahead to
effectively protect the most vulnerable
with a third booster
as well as of course we're already doing
the immunosuppressed uh with as part of
their primary
vaccine treatment
sorry minister the reason i push on this
is at times this week it does feel like
the messaging from government has been
in different places at the weekend you
know that's an end no vaccine passports
the following day we find out that they
remain on the table telling the prime
minister incredibly optimistic but at
the same time suggesting there are
circumstances in which as you've just
conceded we could go back into lockdown
i mean it's a little bit early in the
year to be asking these kind of
questions i will concede but you can't
for example guarantee right now that
we'll all be able to spend christmas
with our families can you
so look the important thing to remember
is as we embark on the winter months the
virus have an inbuilt advantage whether
it be flu or the covered virus as chris
whittie set out yesterday would be uh
full heart it'd suggest that you know
this thing has already transitioned from
pandemic to endemic that is the
direction that we're taking a massive
booster campaign a really fit for
purpose surveillance variant
surveillance system a really fit for
purpose test and trace system that is
where we
think we will be able to end up we're
confident that we have the
infrastructure in place to deliver on
this but of course look we we have to
have contingency planning there is
all the time
more information coming in on how the
virus is behaving winter has a gives the
virus an inbuilt advantage boosters
reduce that advantage by you know
hopefully uh uh taking the most
vulnerable out of harm's way of the body
i i understand all that i understand all
of that minister i'm really i'm really
not looking for some kind of gotcha
moment here all i'm trying to kind of to
flesh out is the idea that we are not
out of the woods in terms of covert even
if things go as well as you expect you
know there remains the possibility
however likely or unlikely that we could
see ourselves returning to you know
public health responses the likes of
which we have seen you know in the
recent past
so again i just repeat for your viewers
um the non-pharmaceutical interventions
the lock downs were our only tool that
is no longer true that we have the
vaccines we have the test and trace
system we have the surveillance the
various surveillance system
we have the public health advice which
people followed of all ages you know
really really diligently which has
allowed us to take step four to reopen
uh our economy and
the booster campaign with flu will help
basically protect the most vulnerable
as we transition i hope this virus and i
can come back on your program and say to
you uh after winter's over hand on heart
we are the you know one of the leading
major economies of the world to
demonstrate how you transition the virus
from pandemic to endemic and then deal
with it on an annual basis through the
uh inoculation the vaccination program
we will we will all be keeping our
fingers crossed that that is the case i
i do wonder though what your advice
would be to colleagues within your party
who are openly expressing skepticism
about one key aspect of all of this the
vaccination of 12 to 15 year olds marcus
fish tweeted this sorry to have to say
it but the chief medical officer chris
whittie does not deserve the confidence
of the country in deciding to vaccinate
teenagers without good clinical reason
his words he the chief medical officer
should resign what would you say to mr
fish this morning
well all i would say is that
both the jcbi who in their guidance said
look
it is marginally more beneficial
to be uh vaccinated the 12 healthy 12 15
year olds it's well worth reminding uh
your audience that we've been
vaccinating 12th teen year olds who are
more vulnerable uh as per the jcbi
advice the jcbi advice also
said that we should consult the four
chief medical officers and they have
unanimously come back this is not just
chris whittie this is all four chief
medical officers of england scotland
wales and northern ireland to give us
the advice that we should make the
vaccine available uh 212 to funerals who
are healthy and for their parents to
consent and that is exactly what we will
be doing